The underdog.
The long shot.
The dark horse.
Sometimes, you just can't help but cheer for the David over the CS:GO-liath.
I'm looking at you BIG.
That's why this week on Best of we're taking a look at those Davids of the CS:GO world.
Guys, these are players who defied our expectations of them.
Who stepped up a weight class to show they can go toe-to-toe with the best teams, and players in the world.
(casting)
You know guys, players get injured.
It happens.
And when they do there is a roster hole to fill.
Now, the person who substitutes is usually not the one with the entire team on their back.
And yet, it happens.
This next section highlights those coaches and subs who stepped the f--k up for their team
when they really needed it.
I'm looking at you, Cromen.
(casting)
You know, guys, everybody has
a rookie season and even the most iconic of
CS:GO champions were once
simply contenders.
That's why this next section looks at the CS:GO superstars of today BEFORE their trophy cases were full.
(casting)
Well guys, that’s all I've got for you on Best of this week.
Now, if there is one take away from this video that I want you to have it's to
keep following your passions, always persevere,
exercise your potential
and never forget your dreams.
Oh, and subscribe to theScore esports.
See ya next week!